y poco a poco se van conociendo los
resultados de la conformación del
parlamento escocés y por supuesto hay
gran expectativa por saber si existe el
mandato de la gente para un segundo
referendo recordemos el primero de
independencia se realizó en el 2014 y
ganó la opción de mantenerse dentro del
reino unido- hasta el momento de 129
sillas posibles se han conocido 48
sillas el resultado son 39 para el
partido nacional escocés ls en pique
está en el gobierno y que es el que está
prometiendo este segundo referendo esto
nos muestra la tendencia sin embargo
para que sea más claro este mandato
político el partido nacional escocés
necesita 65 sillas de 129 posibles como
les cuento se espera que en el
transcurso de esta tarde e incluso
mañana estos resultados puedan conocerse
el primer ministro boris johnson ha sido
claro y hoy lo ha reiterado sus
ministros
el país no puede permitir este segundo
referendo no es el momento político y no
lo permitiría pero lo cierto es que si
los nacionalistas escoceses obtienen
estas mayorías aplastantes el primer
ministro por lo menos políticamente no
podría negarse a este segundo referendo
se espera que además en el transcurso de
hoy o de mañana se conozca si hay
reelección en londres si el musulmán
shavit can puede seguir en este cargo
por cinco años más